Let's compare notes. When I ran this, surprisingly, I did not get the answer,
they are the same. Here's what I got. It says, firstAndSecond is Udacity. So
why isn't it the same as third, which is also Udacity? Let me explain.
FirstAndSecond is a variable. Any object variable contains a reference to the
object, like this. The string object contains the letters Udacity. Let's look
at our other variable. Again, a variable just holds a reference. Now, reference
to which object? Is it a reference to the same string object or to a different
one? And that is the key question. The equal equal operator. Checks whether the
contents of these two variables is exactly the same. In other words, whether
both variables refer the exact same object. Now actually, they don't. Because
if you remember what happened, firstAndSecond was obtained by gluing together
this string and that string. And a brand new object had to be created to hold
that content the third string was initialized with the literal string, Udacity,
which came from elsewhere. So, in this case, the objects are different. But we
don't actually care about that. What we care about is, do they have the same
contents? And to compare the contents, one has to use the equals method. And
not the equal, equal operator. Let's do that. Over here, I will check whether
firstAndSecond equals third. Here's the test. We call the equals method on
firstAndSecond and pass it third as a parameter. Now when we run the program,
it will work as expected. The program prints, they are the same. So the take
away is, when comparing strings, use the equals method and not the equal equal
operator. And as a reminder, when comparing decimal numbers. Be sure to check
whether the numbers are close to each other, and also don't use equal equal.
Now when do you use equal equal? For integers, of course.